en directo a vamos a Ciudad de México
porque el Gobierno Federal liderado por
Andrés Manuel López Obrador está
tramitando ya la solicitud de asilo que
ratificó el expresidente peruano Pedro
Castillo recordemos que ayer 7 de
diciembre Castillo disolvió el congreso
y los legisladores respondieron
destituyéndolo cuando Castillo intentó
huir a la embajada de México en Lima lo
arrestaron y este jueves la justicia le
ordenó 7 días de detención preventiva
mientras se realiza su juicio por
presunta rebelión vamos entonces a la
capital Mexicana donde estaba nuestro
corresponsal Mario carbonell Mario
buenas noches para usted La mayoría de
los presidentes latinoamericanos ya
reconocieron a Dina boluarte como la
presidenta de Perú y quien antes era la
vicepresidenta qué Argumenta Andrés
Manuel López Obrador para no hacerlo
Hola pues de hecho le han preguntado al
presidente Porque si la mayoría de los
presidentes latinoamericanos de
izquierda han dado su reconocimiento
México no lo ha hecho López Obrador dijo
que pues México es un país libre
independiente y que no nos gusta el
seguidismo así lo así lo calificó dijo
que vamos a esperar unos días a que se
aclare la situación que está todo muy
fresco y que no es la intención de
México intervenir en asuntos internos de
otros países no obstante no se guardó su
opinión respecto del caso dijo que pues
Pedro Castillo había sido víctima de una
campaña de acoso por parte de la
oligarquía peruana que no había aceptado
su triunfo legítimo y que pues incluso
Consideró que había racismo en su contra
en ese sentido Bueno sí se decantó por
una defensa de Pedro castillo y dijo que
vamos a esperar que la cancillería
mexicana va a analizar en los próximos
si da o no el reconocimiento a Dina
boluarte y precisamente sobre López
Obrador fue el propio presidente
mexicano quien primero reveló que
Castillo había pedido asilo a México y
también agregó que se lo iba a nadar por
eso el embajador mexicano fue a visitar
a Castillo a la cárcel Qué se sabe y
Cuál es la posición del gobierno
mexicano
Así es el presidente mexicano reveló que
fue a través de una llamada telefónica
aquí a Palacio Nacional que Pedro
Castillo solicitó que le abrieran las
puertas de la Embajada Mexicana en Lima
y que en ese momento López Obrador Buscó
al canciller Marcelo ebrar para que
gestionara la recepción de Castillo cosa
que no fue posible dado su arresto pero
en efecto el propio Marcelo ebrard dijo
que el embajador mexicano Pablo Monroy
visitó ya en la cárcel a Pedro Castillo
que se encuentra bien que estaba en
compañía de su abogado y que va México a
iniciar las consultas con las
autoridades peruanas para ver la
posibilidad de este asilo que fue
solicitado a través de una carta una
carta del abogado de Castillo Víctor
Pérez liendo en la que pues dice que
Castillo es víctima de una persecución
política que lo quieren procesar por el
mero anuncio de una voluntad o de una
intención y que eso no constituye ningún
delito de orden penal de modo que pues
están ya el procedimiento
de entrada Dina boluarte Espera que
López Obrador le entregue la presidencia
pro tempore de la alianza del Pacífico
pero este tema también está en veremos
dijo López Obrador que se va a Pues a
consultar con los otros países para ver
qué procede bueno varios temas quedan en
veremos como usted lo dice Mario y
gracias por este reporte de nosotros
continuamos con directo América